moi mes amours d'antan
c'était de la vitesse dans ce cas et
fanchon la cousette pas la moindre
noblesse excusez moi du peu
c'était me direz-vous des grâces
roturière des nymphes le ruisseau lait
venus de barrières mon prince on a les
dames du temps jadis qu'on peut
car le coeur à 20 ans se pose où l'on se
pose
le premier cotillons venu vous impose la
plus humble bergère est un beau saut de
roi sans manquer de marquise ont connu
la soubrette portes de fleurs de lys onu
la pâquerette au printemps cupidon fait
flèche de tout bois ont rencontré la
belle aux puces le dimanche je te plaît
tu me plais et c'était dans la manche
et les grands sentiments n'était pas de
rigueur
je te plaît tu me plais bien dont hbo
militaire dans un train de banlieue ont
pas vep aussi tu es
on n'était pas tenue même d'apporter son
coeur mimi de prime abord payer guère de
mine chez son coureur sans doute
on ignorait les remis son habit sortait
point de l'atelier d'un vieux mais quand
par dessus le moulin de la galette elle
jetait pour vous sa parure simplette
c'est psyché tout temps qu'elle kivu
sautait aux yeux
pour ce second rendez-vous y avait
parfois personnes elle avait fait faux
bond la petite amazon mais l'on ne
pourrait pas se prendre pour autant
la marguerite commencé avec suzette on
finissait de les feux hier avec yvette
et l'amour il tomber quand même sont
contents c'était me direz-vous des
grâces hauturière des nymphes de
ruisseaux
les venus de barrières mais c'étaient
mes amours excusez moi du peu
des manants des mini les six ont des
musettes margot la blanche kayes et
penchons la cousette mon prince ona les
dames du temps jadis qu'on peut